switching gears a little bit what
motivates the two of you to stay in this
business what is it it was it the first
thing that initially you know you'd
started modeling and back I don't know
New York or something and then
transition to acting but what motivates
you to continue on and has that
motivation change has it shifted there's
something I i can't speak for her
because obviously we have I mean it's as
as much of a unit as we are we do kind
of separate ourselves with things I mean
she's an actor and you know my side of
it is completely different I think for
me there is something deep inside that
it is tapped into you know that I was
not aware of as I gone into maturity or
anything like that i think that the
being able to tell important stories and
to be able to pull that from a deeper
place the satisfaction is beyond the
fame or the money or anything it's
because there isn't any of that clearly
not about that the collaborative side of
it you know was very much this this
thing that I was not aware of and it's
that's the drive I mean now that this
has happened I plan on doing this until
I'm in a wheelchair and dead and I'm not
going anywhere so for me I think
motivation I don't look at necessarily
motivational for me it's I am constantly
learning yeah I get to always be
expanding my head and I'm always in a
place of creation and to be able to tell
of it like our next one is crafty it's a
craft show mockumentary Donna is a broad
comedy and and hopefully at the same
time porreca which is a true story about
a drug kingpin you know its ultimate
rise fall and redemption so and I've
done I get a grade I get to learn about
that world and I get to learn about this
world and be able to share that with
people and you fall into these things
and they just become something I don't
know what it is maybe it's something in
our crazies mental psyche in the
Hollywood world where you you feel so
compelled that you have to and it's the
spa
the pain and the ups and the downs and
the struggles it's just something that
you have to share you know that's one of
the things that I think after has taught
us and now going into future projects
there's such a an eye-opening experience
for the whole gamut of the business but
just the the need to share this with
other people in the world you know yeah
I just like to learn I just love
learning every every project is
different you know growing up I was like
that Oh today I'm gonna be an astronaut
today I'm gonna be a doctor Oh today I'm
gonna do this oh you know what
veterinarian and you know and it became
clear that you know perhaps you may want
to think about you know I knew as a kid
but I was pushed to college and business
and stuff and then I came back to it so
um because I just I love step in and
shoes for a little that time period and
learning that as much as I can it's a
driving force of crude but just crave it
knowledge and I get to do that any
advice for people back in rochester that
want to come to LA do it follow your
passion you mean you're talking to
people that jump off cliffs and figure
it out on the way down so do it you
bring a parachute no hmmmm I mean you'd
live life it's not just Rochester it's
jump go for do you follow your follow
your love and your passion and it'll
just don't give up winston churchill no
see
you